ich hoffe einfach für dich wert auch für
die beten dass du überlebst bresch war
haben die ärzte gesagt dass du
irgendwelche so hast du hast die
überlebenschancen zu wie viel prozent
sind deine überlebenschance dass man
leute check mal dass ihr youtube seite
und ihr nehmt ein video auf und auf fake
lover tier davon wo ich bete dafür dass
überlebt was sind deine
überlebenschancen es sind wirklich schon
einige leute über 8000 weltweit und du
machst du krank video darüber ist ein
ernst das aktuell in deutschland
unterwelt umgehende bier virus führt
dazu dass sehr viele leute sich so
zeigen wie sie wirklich sind manche
bunkern töten papier
manche chillen weiterhin draußen in
großen gruppen und feiern weiter partys
und komplett drauf dass das alte
menschen in der gesellschaft gefährdet
und wieder andere zeigen sich von ihrer
besten seite stecken mal kurz ein paar
wochen zurück und erkennen auch den sinn
hat und dieses zeigen wenn man wirklich
es geht nicht nur für die breite
gesellschaft in deutschland in der welt
sondern auch für deutschlands instagram
youtuber für deutschland und es stellt
sich heraus dass und es kommt sicher
sehr überraschend für euch sehr
nennenswerter anteil von deutschlands
interessen von deutschlands youtube und
instagram man einfach geisteskranke
dumpfbacken sind es ist wirklich so wir
haben ihn sogar in deutschland die nach
ausbruch des virus noch mal schnell in
den urlaub fliegen und sich dann aus dem
urlaub ins tor beschweren wir haben die
tür in deutschland die mit
gemeingefährlichen verschwörungstheorien
um sich werfen so tun als wenn das ganze
nicht echt und jetzt gestern hat ein
deutscher youtuber sozusagen noch mal
die kirche auf die torte oben drauf
gepackt und hat so getan gefaked als
würde ein zuschauer von ihm an dem bier
virus sterben
kleine besser der besagt youtuber heißt
sie max hat ein video hochladen junge
hat ca
und wird sterben ich erfülle in seinen
letzten wunsch in fort madison tue alles
klar oh ich bin sehr gespannt auf dieses
qualitativ hochwertige video hat gerade
einfach ein abonnent auf instagram
geschrieben das saatvirus hat und dass
einer seiner letzten bildschirm er mit
mir zu zocken und er meinte auch so
sachen wie er hat nur noch paar tage und
leute ohne witz ich bin immer wieder
schockiert wie sie max ich will jetzt
nicht persönlich beleidigen aber du
musst das jetzt einfach mal als kritik
an der sache irgendwie hängengeblieben
manche leute sind wie wenig skrupel
manche leute haben egal was es ist zu
instrumentalisieren und zu nutzen um
noch ein paar aufrufe mehr zu machen
wohl größter der anstand dass ich es
nicht daraufhin habe ich ihn direkt
gerettet und ich hoffe wirklich diesmal
hoffe ich wirklich dass es nicht ernst
gemeint ist und dass der junge nur mit
mir zu tun weil normalerweise können ja
nur alte leute oder leute mit einem na
ja klassiker also einige sachen an
dieser geschichte machen auf jeden fall
von anfang an schon mal sind die
allererste sache die sinn macht ist dass
jemand der kurz davor ist das zeitliche
zu segnen natürlich zu hause am pc
schild und bisschen mal ein bisschen
zocken zu einem youtuber weil solche
leute liegen ja dann nicht im
krankenhaus oder so und ich bete einfach
zu gott dass das gerade ein spaß ist ich
habe ihn jetzt eingeladen und lasst mal
alle neukunden aber da das wenn er das
video sieht das wie viele leute
eigentlich hinter ihm stehen
heute sollte wie viele gehört sind in
diesem kopf noch drin ich glaube ich
kann es alleine hand abzählen
also wie gesagt es sieht also dieses
video hier siehst meine absicht ist
wirklich nicht ich persönlich zu
verletzen oder anzugreifen
aber sag mal was für einen hängen
gebliebenen star gerade gemacht hast
checkt das mal
es sind wirklich schon einige leute über
8000 weltweit dahin gestorben
und du machst du krank video darüber ist
ein ernst hallo hallo und man wird sie
nächste echte ja was geht es so ich
glaube ich glaube mein bruder aber jetzt
mal ganz offen und ehrlich also das war
jetzt wirklich nur spaß ja ja der
schauspielerei schlechter als hilfe mehr
unter wird's wahrscheinlich kommt auch
eine personen die das gesundheitlich so
schlecht geht das ist halt wirklich eng
wird für sie so rein in die runde wird
so es muss weil es gut
genau so hören sich solche leute an und
die zocken auch noch vor neid alles
gleich gebt mir ein kopfschuss leute
ganz kurz werde ich dieses video hier
gerade geschnitten habe hat sie mix auf
seinem kanal ein entschuldigungs video
hochgeladen was ich sehr seltsam finde
was es in keiner art und weise
rechtfertigt er sagt er einerseits und
wie konnte ich das machen andererseits
lässt das video trotzdem online so
erzählt zeigt zwar dass ist uk bis das
nächste geld damit verdient aber das ist
trotzdem da die natürlich wirklich für
dieses video so schön ist wie du sagst
dann löschen
ok bestätigt den fehler ein löscht das
video und denken darüber nach ob du
vielleicht irgendein betrag an irgendein
hilfsorganisation für dieses thema für
diese krankheit spenden willst aber
jetzt mal ganz offen und ehrlich also
das war jetzt wirklich nur spaß ja du
wolltest einfach nur mit mir zocken ist
einmal ganz offen und ehrlich weil ich
sagte ehrlich über so etwas macht man
keinen scheiß drauf
bringt texte was sogar sagst du sagst
auch selbst du bist zwar in deiner rolle
von wo angeblich hat mein zuschauer das
aber du sagst selbst dann macht man
keinen spaß
aber youtube videos macht man darüber
oder wie oder klick macht man darüber
also das ist okay oder wie ok das ist ja
interessant gerade du hast wer auf
instagram geschrieben dass du nur noch
paar tage wenn nicht sogar paar stunden
zu leben hast wegen diesen videos will
hat nur mein zimmer werden
doch nun fordert zocken bevor es zu ende
geht sollte schaut euch einfach dieses
gesicht an
doch dieses gesicht eine das gehirn was
hinter dieser schläft wer steckt hinter
diesem schere hat sich gedacht ich mache
einfach mal ein video in dem ich mich
mal komplett unterm strich komplett über
die aktuelle situation lustig mache so
ich nehme das was gerade in deutschland
passiert überhaupt nicht ernst mir
vollkommen egal und nicht einfach mal so
und nutze so bisschen die angst der
leute rund um das thema aus fünf in
patricks mehr
das problem ist halt ich hab halt auch
erstmalig kennen sie bestimmt hier das
hält chronisch in der chronische
erkrankung dass der chor nicht nur
husten und andere sachen und jetzt
bringt auch atembeschwerden oder dabei
weiß ich es ist einfach ekelhaft leute
das ist new york einfach klappt was ist
noch schöner macht ist weil es pro texte
was da gerade machst du ja das ist
wirklich auf einem level mit den bomben
brink von apa red das ist ein level von
einfach menschlich gesehen abstoßen
jacob rom eine eigene schwester bis 15
die haspa okay gut kannst dir vorstellen
mich das finde wenn du in deinem video
jobs oder machst du da war dann bei dir
irgendwie ein arzt oder so zu hause der
diakonie us druck notiert hat
erneute break es ist ein break man muss
sie max ist ein break muss man sagen das
ist natürlich die erste frage die sich
stellt waren arzt bei ihm zu hause der
des b virus diagnostiziert hat also
wurde da eine diagnose gestellt oder war
das ohne das ist eine wichtige frage na
ja also die waren erst mal meiner mutter
haben mit der geräte da kann die hat
mein zimmer mutter war am heulen dies
dass das war schon sehr belastend für
mich und daran die er jetzt hat
mitgeteilt dass es so ist und ich halt
ohne hoffnung habe aber die nicht so
hoch ist stellt euch vor leute ihr seid
einfach so geistig hängengeblieben in
eurem kopf das ist ja sogar zwei leute
also er und ich vermute der andere typ
ist ein kumpel von ihm dem erhalt
aufgetragen hat ja ja ich hab ne killer
idee für youtube tun alle so als hättest
du es und tun wir so als wäre ein
ernster fall denkt ihr über story dazu
aus egal in welcher welt leben wir dass
solche leute und ich sage es noch mal
ohne die absicherung persönlich
anzugreifen in welcher welt leben wir
dass solche leute vorbilder für
jugendliche und für kinder sind checke
ich nicht und du machst jetzt wirklich
gar keinen spaß
du machst jetzt wirklich gar keinen spaß
und das wirklich zu einem 1 1
ich sage dir ehrlich das vermiest
gottlos sie mixt ich weiß nicht was es
ist ob das irgendwie noch so ein teil
von deinem gehirn lässt sich das
unterbewusstsein was du sagst was macht
denn was machst du gerade braucht aber
du kannst dich die ganze zeit selbst aus
ja ja es ist gottlos es wäre gottlos
wenn jemand das vorgeben würde
mindestens genauso gottlos ist es die
ganze situation zu wecken und zu stellen
und dann am ende in kleinen klammern
krank zu schreiben und dann so susanne
11 ich stelle meine komplette familie
darüber machen
ein spaß weil ich sagte ehrlich wenn das
wirklich stimmt so nicht den tod sollte
man fürchten sondern dass man nie
beginnen wird zu leben weißt du mich mal
leute ich muss wirklich sagen mein
intelligenzquotient sinkt mit jeder
minute die ich mir dieses video
anschauen was war das jetzt für ein
spruch man soll was noch mal nicht den
tod sollte man fürchten sondern dass man
nie beginnen wird zu leben hängen
geblieben ich hoffe einfach für dich
wert auch für die beten dass du
überlebst schwer haben die ärzte gesagt
dass du irgendwelche so hast du hast die
überlebenschancen zu wie viel prozent
sind eine überlebenschance zeigt dass
man leute tag mal dass ihr youtube seite
und ihr nehmt ein video auf und auf fake
lover tier davon wo ich bete dafür dass
überlebt was sind deine
überlebenschancen und check mal dass er
in dem moment einfach nicht in grund und
boden versinkt oder einfach die auftrag
die aufnahme abrecht uns einfach last
egal wo ist also der kontrollmechanismus
in deinem kopf der sagt braucht mein
leben schon sind jetzt nicht
unwahrscheinlich aber auch nicht richtig
hoch 23 prozent das jetzt nicht hoch
auch nicht wo da ab wo darf ja ich will
auf jeden fall auch mit bruder aber es
ist okay wenn ich aufnehme ist okay wenn
ich youtube-video draus mache und ich
ein titel schreiber so weißt du neu
angehen muss ja besorgt und betankt
werden ist ja ganz klar ja ich fall
wirklich vom glauben ab wisst ihr was
das problem ist meine oma oder mein
vater so schauen sie mal auf youtube
wright und sehen dann sowas ja denken
sich dann so was macht mein sohn was
macht mein enkel dafür einen
geisteskranken müll sowas ruiniert
wirklich den ruf von youtube italien
30 minuten einladenden coroner wir es
einfach darum geht ja ich wirklich sehr
gute ausbeute
darum gehen da bleiben in italien so
circa 420 verstorbene in den letzten 24
stunden gesehen
420 durch 24 erteilt das 17 halb also
sind es 17 pro stunde und nicht eine
alle 30 minuten
es sind über acht alle 30 minuten ihrem
an alter oder ich muss er noch eins
sagen wer hätte ich komplett
hochgenommen ich habe gar kein corona
syz co der highscore ich habe es meinen
kühlschrank das ist das bier und so
endet das video dann damit der am ende
noch seinen arsch retten kann man sagen
kann ja alles war nur ein break aber der
aus der aktion kannst du dein arsch
retten soll
das disqualifiziert einfach es ist
wirklich unter aller sau ich finde du
sollst dich schämen allen leuten
gegenüber die ernste probleme damit
haben ich will auch nicht moralapostel
spielen aber jeder der einen funken
verstand im kopf hat jack dass das
einfach unter aller sau ist er hat
gerade eben muss man auch sagen noch
irgendwie eine antwort video hochgeladen
juckt mich nicht ich mir nicht rein das
ist einfach eine automation dass das
video immer noch online löschs einfach
und entschuldigt sich dass das mindeste
was du machen kannst okay ist es
trotzdem nicht das was so weit von mir
heute schriftlich kommentare wie sehr er
den glauben an die menschheit in diesem
video verloren haben für euch
veranstaltet wieder ab und abonniert
diesen kanal auf dem ich mich in zukunft
auch weiterhin nicht über solche
angelegenheiten lustig machen werde weil
ich tatsächlich noch ein zweiter stelle
mit im schädel hat bleibt zu hause
vermeidet große gruppen leute
wahrscheinlich die hände